all right so the Boogeyman has slowly
creeped into theaters the latest Stephen
King adaptation and I'm I'm not gonna
lie they're uh there's some scary stuff
scurrying about here so in this video
we're gonna be breaking down this latest
Fright Fest explaining the ending
differences between the movie and
Stephen King's short story the symbolism
of the boogeyman along with our thoughts
of the film spoilers inbound so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out
then I highly recommend you close the
closet door now but do please hit that
like button and make sure to subscribe
for breakdowns like this every day with
all of that out of the way thank you so
much for clicking this again I am Jared
now don't turn off that light dad you
have to listen to me okay
I'm listening
sweetheart let me handle
so with the boogeyman being based on
Stephen King's short story by the same
name Rob Savage and crew took some of
the lore and twisted things a bit with
this movie almost being a foe follow-up
to that book as the opening shows us the
daughter of Lester Billings being
attacked by the Fable Boogeyman as a bit
of a cold open showing the intensity and
some attributes of this fabled creature
the story then settles on our main
family of the Harpers will and his two
daughters Sadie and Sawyer as it deluded
that their wife slash mother had
recently perished in a car accident as
all of them struggled to get back to the
normalcy of daily life both daughters
returned back to school and will returns
back to his role at stay at home or
therapist when a Shifty Man shows up
unannounced to Dr Harper's office
begging to talk this is Lester Billings
from the opening of the movie and main
character from Stephen King's short
story as he lays out his story for Dr or
Harper Lester confides in Dr Harper
explaining how his infant child had
passed away due to SIDS bringing grief
upon his family which soon then followed
by his two other children mysteriously
passing due to unknown circumstances
with the public thinking that he and his
wife were murderers however Lester
believes that he and his family were
being stalked by something something
something of a supernatural entity
showing a sketch of it to Harper while
being frightened by this slightly ajar
Closet in Dr Harper's office after some
reassurance will cause the authorities
because of Lester's erratic Behavior as
Lester then wanders upstairs of the
Harper's home Sadie had ditched school
earlier that day and here's some strange
banging and wrestling noises coming from
their late mother's Art Studio she then
finds Lester's lifeless body hanging
from the back of the closet door in her
studio now the main thing we learned
throughout this is that the boogeyman is
drawn to quote wounded victims typically
one suffering from loss grief some sort
of trauma and the fear of these victims
uh almost acts as like a food source for
the ancient unknown creature this toying
with its food continues with several
frightful sequences as Sadie reminisces
over some of her mother's belongings in
their basement finding a lighter that
belongs to her mother she's curious if
her mother's spirit is there with them
watching them protecting over them and
as a test she asks her mother to move
the lighter's flame slightly to the left
however the flame does not move these
further attacks cause Sadie to wander
into the billing's old home only to find
Lester's wife acting all crazy old lady
type hunting this unknown Beast like the
old man from the end of Jeepers Creepers
2. this is where Sadie learns of the
monster's Tendencies its motives and so
forth leading to her and her family
having a much larger Target on them as
later that evening the boogeyman drags
around the young Sawyer tossing her into
the television set like a 2008 Rogue Wii
moat while playing bowling sending her
to the hospital Lester's wife calls
Sadie at the hospital telling her that
she's found a way to stop the beast but
it's all a trap tying up Sadie's bait to
lure out the old bogeyman from hiding
but the thing is the room is rigged like
an adult Kevin McAllister Contraption
resulting in the boogeyman being pelted
with dozens of shotgun shells once it
steps on a tripwire like Dutch always
says if it breathes we can kill it so
with this new information Sadie runs
home to find her father and sister now
prisoners to the boogeyman almost using
them as bait to get to her Sadie goes
back down into their basement Casey
Jones style fighting off the creature
with a hockey stick until she's pinned
and her Essence is slowly devoured by
the boogeyman I I'm gonna be honest I
have no idea it looked like the Death
Eater stealing something out of her but
then Dr Harper steps in stabbing the
creature with the broken hockey stick
freeing Sadie as she then attempts to
ignite her mother's lighter once again
only for the flame to shine brighter
than before or slightly moving to the
left as a sign her mother's spirit is
finally with them City then lights that
some beach up with some hairspray and
gasoline resulting in some crispy fried
Boogie as the family escapes the home
watching as everything burns down I'm
assuming what his days potentially weeks
later we see Dr Harper and his two
daughters all in therapy together
finally confronting the trauma grief and
loss together the things the boogeyman
was thriving on are now healed as a
bonded family unit but as they are about
to leave Sadie hears the therapist call
her back into her office only to find an
empty room with the closet door slightly
ajar oh the boogeyman is still
there just like the short story but
instead of fear Sadie closes the closet
as a symbol that she is healed the past
is in the past and she is okay with
moving forward with life grief will
always be with her but will no longer
consume her control her life as closing
the door literally and metaphorically uh
symbolizes this as for the boogeyman
overall I think that this was a somewhat
effective horror film some might say
that it's more of an elevated horror
film because of the real life
metaphorical implications of it dealing
with you know a lot more things that
people can probably relate to themselves
from the loss the grief depression and
so forth but it's also a Creature
Feature monster movie so it's kind of in
this weird position trying to pull
overtime I was scared do not get me
wrong and the camera movements helped
with those frights whether it be
painting to a character to distract us
from something in the background or the
boogeyman like I said is just lurking
around in the background for an
unsuspecting character there's a
specific shot of the youngest Harper
looking under her bed and the camera
flipping was the perfect disorienting
way to take things in this scene in the
end does it all work no not not entirely
I think the acting specifically Vivian
Blair and Sophie Thatcher really bring
us into this world and the lore of the
boogeyman combined with the idea of
grief and Trauma and how it can
effectively affect people differently
but in the end deteriorates a person's
mind slowly over time I thought I
thought that those aspects were the
strongest I also thought that the
creature design even though much of the
time it shrouded in darkness therefore
leaving a lot up for imagination really
worked in this film attaching itself to
the grief and Trauma I had just
mentioned I I I'd give the boogeyman I
don't know in a 6.1 ish out of 10 just
because it doesn't necessarily do
anything new it's it's quite paint by
the Numbers predictable and the lore and
mechanics of the boogeyman are sort of
left to again our imagination it's
taking elements from it follows Relic
from 2020 smile Darkness Falls and a few
others and like is it teleporting are
there multiple of them was it a human at
some time or is it literally just a
creature from Monsters Inc trying to
make a living folks it is tough in this
economy I I don't know anyway that is
everything that we thought on the
boogeyman was this one of 2023 scariest
movies or was this just another horror
movie running through the motions let us
know all of your thoughts in the
comments down below also if you want to
support this Channel please do your fans
of us so please support us for as little
as 99 cents a month then please click
the join button below and as a thank you
you'll get early access to videos every
single week you'll be in a special
secret group
we also have our merch over at
xeroedition.com which sells a lot of
nerdy inspired t-shirts hats all sorts
of things and we actually recently
launched our brand new scroll fiction
shirt it looks good look at that thing
so if you want to head over there and
help us out then the links are also in
the description and of course if you
want something else to watch check out
these cool videos right over here we're
ramping up more classic movie breakdowns
so treat yourself and stay tuned for
even more with all of that out of the
way though thank you a huge thank you
for sitting through this video I've been
your host to Jared I'll see in the next
one take care and peace close that close
that class
close it